this afternoon I'll talk about computers
that in what you can do with it and
I will speak beginning and at the end of the presentation
also what is cloud computing?
how google cloud platform enters
to answer you hopefully to yours
needs to your problems
then the cloud platform offers so many
services
the most famous that we offer since 6
7 years if I'm not mistaken, it's google app
engine is a system that basically
see a front end that scales
automatically an application for you
you write the code this code goes
on a car
if you have so many many requests
maybe new instances are created 123
another ten or a hundred instances that you
will allow to honor the requests
of your customers without having a day time
out after ten seconds because maybe
they are all on your site
you do not know a newspaper online the first
ten people succeed in your heaven
newspaper after one thousand two thousand 10 thousand e
100 thousand there is always a number above
above which your server will
sits and fails to serve a
honoring requests and your customers
they no longer go to your site and you
lose customers you lose money app engine
answers this question computer g that
it's fairly recent we launched a
year ago a year and a half ago and is now
now available to all of you instead
answer another question the possibility
to create virtual machines online
machines for now only linux but a
short we will have other machines than others
guy
in which you can install the software
what you want suppose nothing changed
I don't know a Java library
especially a track that runs on
a car
unique are windows machines but not
works in hosting systems
traditional then competent in
could be the answer he does for
you
and as I said this morning competent not
only offers virtual machines
offers an entire ecosystem in which these
machines live so you can create
network you can create loads
balancer of the firewall rules yes
apply only to certain networks you want to have
the network of mz the deformed network we will see
later cultured create discs attack them
detach them create snap shot create one
machine you like the fact one
slapshot you instantiate one disk in another
area type in america and allocated the
machine starting from this disk
maybe spaced 10 then struggled for
some reason grows the pull down
from the same the snap shot you pull up of
new the eighth that the call with a
another name is somehow using
of the mechanisms I can show you
the system takes this into account and uses it
for example the load balancer can
help them achieve the purpose of
reach a certain number of machines
a bunch of machines without a bunch
worry about their names
ip address have because there is a
level of in the direction that comes
managed directly from our front
end
ok then we have cloud storage that a
system that allows you an object store
allows you to store data
imagine very large static files for
example images music video or data of
a telescope for example
then we have in our offer of
cloud sequel which has very interesting is
a never-ending sequel is therefore a database
traditional then relational opposite
to the data store that those of you familiar with app
engine knows well, raise your hand
who of you has used app engine and the
own life ok not bad
who of you has used any other
what is the fault based on cloud storage or
to computer gen
ok you're lying because so many of you are
a morning pasta but let's pretend to
anything
ok thanks other offers other parties
offer
cloud platform are translate è pia e
prediction api ai that allow you to
insert from the source data if di
make predictions to understand and for the
mind a classifier allows you to
understand if something left right
or if something is good or bad by giving it
mixture of initial data in which you
taught how to behave as a system
obviously we will not talk about this
afternoon we will talk only about
computer g ok however just to give you a
framework a cloud computing framework
I think the most important word of
this slide sias that or the cloud
computing allows you to do something that
in the traditional way you can't
just do
you can create any one
idea whatever project you have
you can no longer make it just with one
car but with the machines and the thing
nice if you go to think about the fact that
you pay every minute the car in
su is that you can multiply the number of
cars and basically if you have
written the program with a certain
criterion you can manage to get the
your result in a tenth of the time
so in the end yes the price yes
balance is not that you have to think about create
10 thousand machines split as I spend
because maybe these machines find again
the result in a ten-thousandth of the
time of a car obviously is not
just a tenth of a thousandth but
however, the order of magnitude remains if I am
follow then ok let's see what it is
inserts the world of computer and gene
then if you go to the cloud google
dot.com slash console what I invite you
to do if you have a browser
you have a browser that exposes all the
projects that you are likely to be
no one if the first time there
log in if you have already done app engine or
other things because in projects for whom
does not know what a project is
base container inside which
you can create instances of several instances of
computer gini app engine instances
you can create cloud databases
sequels you can create budgets for
objects and all these objects
within a project I am able
to talk to each other, that is, they inherit
a purpose within which
application a can talk to the back end
b for me that nintendo can be
database data store a machine of
computer gene and so on for who it was
this morning at the alcohol lab is practically
the part where we create a car
with the scoop with service accounts that
allow the machine to write or
read from cloud storage are technologies
several united by ep to the municipalities and the
possibility also to make these speak
technologies that then perhaps the biggest
advantage of using the platform
google is the fact that you have so many
different technologies and you can orchestrate them
as you please
the second of yours and not necessity
so a project is basically a
container to which it is associated with billing
who is paying a credit card with
all odds could be one
fly billing if you have turned a little
the bigger you want to be want to pay to
end of month
you have a team of people to whom
associate this project they have that
inherit rights that you have
grant with a grant you can say
this person can create machines
this person cannot create anything but
can read from the database for example later
we have virtual machines that like you
I said they are linux machines
we currently provide debian 67 and centos
you have the well documented possibility in the
site to create machines of other types
you can create a ubuntu a whammy was
a gentoo whatever you like
once you create the image
following the parameters of the
of documentation just google with
image for computer ingenuity and you should
then find it deeply
machines you want
we are working on windows machines
so if you need s
I can't guarantee the timing but
we will also have this windows machines
it's a promised thing
the processors are 2.7 gHz memory
it's about 3.7 gigabytes and that's the
main brick because I don't know if
remember who of you was this morning
you could create the machines n1 n2 n 4 e
n 8 that is the multiplier how many
how many cores do you have in proportion to
basic brick so you can have it
cars with more US more machines with more
ram depending on the type of calculation that
you have to do
ok then let's talk about network
the enel have so much there are
many entities connected to the network
the first network you have yourself
default network called default is the
10000 slash 24 and basic of all
machines you can create a dmz in
another network you can create in theory
you can also have different projects in
different networks project 1 project 2
these would be useless if it were not
for the fact that you have the possibility of
create firewall rules and rules of
routing you can say whenever
a request arrives this mandala
instead to this to this other network but
go to this gateway who knows about how
sort it if you are good at making
routine with linux could be that
you want to do a nice fi
Latvian with ip tables you put us all
the rules you want your nat
use this this bridgehead
to do the routing to the machines
affect
you can let us do this work
that we have a load balancer that makes for
you and think about on other levels of
conquer but if you have to do something
more complex than what we are there
we obviously offer the tools
to do it
ok
so you have networks inside one
network you can create rules of
firewall you can say opens port 80
on the network of mz opened the door 33 06
on the database network and so on
ok with regards to internet
default machines are born with a
public ip address that for aeffem
eric efe merit means that it changes
every time you pull on the machine
different ie you have no guarantors e
quality guarantee you know if you want mipi
static you can buy it
funny is that static lippi is
absolutely free and it's done
pay only when and is touch from one
machine there is the world in which it attacked
the car is free
the moment we do not use
no cars with public ones
so the public ones are external like you
says in Italian is there to do nothing with
fact that we have to pay the rep
to have a rotation of ep we see
this responsibility to be sure
that the ip actually used
but if you use them for any
kind of work questp don't cost you
absolutely nothing so you can
give your customer a regard
my state dns p 1 point 2.3.4
forget it because those more and
yours forever
you can also attack horse racing
you own for other reasons from tea
you can make gissi useful for hunting p
and you have an ip that your company for
some reason to that in anyway ripe
already towards your company
in short, you have lots of possibilities ok
let's talk about a couple of records then
when created a virtual machine
you can have persistent or
skins that mou scratch days that I am
disposable discs
the second is a record that is born and dies
with the with the car means of
disinterested in what's up
this record because maybe it's a
trivial boot disk but the data that you
they are interested in another record that
you can attack
then there are the persistent risks that
vice versa they are guaranteed discs
to be
persistent excuse the duplication
these discs will always remain where
they are guaranteed to be up extra
positions of the same area then
however the province is highly
unlikely to result in corruption
of data or that you lose the disk that is
I say with your heart in your hand is you
rest assured when you have a data on
persistent ska and then suppose to
have a super car stand disk
where you do so many jobs every
add week add load
you can take snap shots which is a
concept here you are definitely used to
maybe with vmware or others it is
virtualized virtualization and therefore
you can also juggle the
concept of snap shot to the concept of
visco ie you can transform a disc
snapshots but also to allocate a disc
from a snap shot the difference that a
disk is attached to an area and is
snapshot somewhere in the cloud no
I tell you where somewhere else anyway
part
you can switch between them and
you can obviously instantiate images a
starting from a disk so you can create
a vanilla installation for example
October 2010 01
2013 10 01 that is your panel e
create ten machines starting from
flavors come an idea wait when I have
forgotten to install to installed peaces
a paci you have the November 01 version
you have another snap shot this time
you can instantiate the vanilla image 2
ok it's instant maybe 10 100 1000 a
depending on what you have to do is
all very simple i assure you ok the
disk is encrypted so there is data is
absolutely safe and not even if the
your project is separate from the project
of other customers
when there was any kind
unauthorized access
anyone who does not have that key does not have
any access to those disks is therefore a
security point of view
we have been careful we also have gods
problems with a customer are asked to
find data for them because it is
really problematic
then another another doubtful disco
another another storage system a
which you can access is cloud storage
I've already talked about it this morning is a yes it is
an object store as I mentioned
you can use it from the command line
you can use it from the web
we have a
google.com slash cloud web page
console allows you to access all the
your projects so you can see i
your files browse these directories
virtual repeats are not drinking directories
you can do interesting things like
these you can use a line of
sorry command if it is a bit grainy gst
free I read gs tmb as make bucket gs
two points bar slash and then the name of the
budget
I created the computer budget g if there
try it should fail because already
exist of sutil is always copied more to
in here and automatically will create
will copy a file you have locally and there
will put in the object or from this moment
this object is persisted is guaranteed
exist forever
as long as you have your designed it goes
obviously jesus tls you can make it lsu
in them less r is practically one
very similar command line compatible
with all the controls you are used to
from the command line and being able to do things
very interesting thing more
interesting of the object store is that
you can redirect a dns to your site
web so you can for example if you have
of any film images of any
what you have on your site you can
make them direct all the static part
of your site
to this object store that may be
replicated in more areas so maybe in
America in Europe and Asia and therefore
have very low latencies and
even low costs with regards to
little eyes think of the reader I don't know
an online newspaper the html part
very small compared to the part of
images
and documents in general therefore may have
meaning to put the static files that are
bigger in another part because
this is faster and less access
expensive ok how to access computer gene
all
all this world is exposed to the outside
through bees to quests have one
version now we are at 1 beta 16
probably slides will offer at 15
because we have a little star on xvi
there are three ways basically for
access the lady at the command line
that at the profit you will find that you will see more
forward and that you used this morning
cheerfully the oye which is the cloud
google.com slash console that as I said
it really is I talked to
developers and we have a team in
america that is working hard on us
and every week we have new features
the nice thing if you want to insert one
create a new web instance that does
of people automatically all
possible instances the images possible
the possible areas so it is much more
easy but from licari command though if
you want to start one hundred machines not
you want to fill out a form a hundred times
cli car 100 times right is like
I don't know a plane book
air tickets all identical
it makes no sense to click a hundred times then
in that case you will have to get your hands dirty
with the command line but then later
you can launch a hundred machines in a turn
a few seconds and I assure you one of mine
colleague did party thousand
machines in 5 minutes and just have the
there is no quota there is no problem
you have an initial quota which is a bit
little girl and to prevent people from doing it
put to start 100 thousand machines and
make our data centers head office though
obviously with time if we are well
pleased with altavilla empty third code
but not least last but not least
we have hypia inscriptions for java
python ego which are the three languages
more supported
from google then we are working on ruby
we are working on php now that it is
been combined with app engine and I think that
we are also working on that though
I can only guarantee for now
python java ego this morning with who it was
the club and we wrote a little program
in python to see a list of
instances that are available in your
project doing so you can make create
a logic of yours yours
liking you can sell computer g in
your customers by offering to our customers
customers by offering an intermediate layer
which adds value as it is doing
and we have two clients who are
basically selling computer gene
to the whole world
offering something more above
obviously they write the code of the
morning to evening offer perhaps
monitoring were resilience offer
of things on top of the service that
we offer we see what is
he calls ben metal which is not really for
goal because they are virtual machines though
what we do are machines
who can be born can die
you must create a system that is in
able to withstand the breaks it is
one thing you always have in the cloud
take into consideration ok
this is a screenshot I made
a few weeks ago, unfortunately, it was not
he sees very well however as you see here
you have an overview of this project
here you have yours
your technologies and then appengine
computer jing cloud storage is
illegible, I apologize but I wanted to
let us stay all here is the name of the
machine we can put a
little more focus you fail
I ask, however, the thing
interesting that here this area and us
central 1 and I think and click here to give you
a list of all the zones and so far e
also uninteresting though
interesting here when yours are there
snap shot this is populated
then automatically via the jacks
when you have a car you have
created a minute ago a snap shot created
minute ago an image created a minute
ago can you tell him look make me this
machine that is called this of this
type taking it from the cosmos image
surprises from the vanilla image made
yesterday and things like that
here is the networking that kind of la
default network dpf merico ep public
etc. etc. access to the process at
project
this is the thing that showed me
this morning for those in the queue from
this is the part where you allow
a virtual machine to access her
automatically like that if you
click on this checkbox that now
do not see an invitation to do so if you have
access computer gene can create one
car that already has the right to
access to certain
certain services and stamps you even if in
car in writing or no type
you want a car to do from
orchestrator to create other machines
something that you have a cloud
elastic you want a car that is
notices if there is too much traffic creates
new machines you want them to have
read write access to the computer
and you don't want anything else
you have another car that does the
cloud storage logging you want that
have the white on.le but no not the rid
maybe for security reasons
maybe ten different customers who
they write in the same buckets you want
they change the law in writing but not
in reading
strange case but can absolutely
happen ok but we have already arrived
towards the end load balancer I mine
purpose
my purpose for this talker to talk
of the load balancer to show you a pair
of scripts I had made etc.
etc
I just want to maybe intrigue a
I guess what the load balancer does
I think I talked about it with Alessandro with
atoms sc to work with us
I think that balances is practically the
second application that each person makes
when when it starts to do
computer the first is apache server see
that works to see that your rights
pia on the page written hello mom is
everything appears and you are happy because
you have grated the car you pulled
on a service you had to configure
the firewall to open port 80
because otherwise you don't access it and this is it
the first satisfaction then say the
widow and eating you this is fin
too easy
the second exercise that one tends to
do wait let's try having ten
machines 10 web servers and each of
they mice I call myself web 1 web2 web 10
now the problem of load balancing is a
problem that many companies are faced with
for over a decade and can have it
brilliantly solved creator three
firewall shifts
companies like google like as amazon or
like many other companies it is not a
problem easy to solve
the idea is this I have a backhand with 100
machines n machines excuse me and I want
make sure that when a person
type www.google.com go to one
random machine that is capable of
offer that service but I don't want to
know that car and I want a level
I don't want to know about holding fiction
machine both but I want when
www.google.com arrives in the car
possibly the closest to me
possibly not charging possibly
so many beautiful things we begin with in the meantime
get a car home that already does not
is a problem recently
you already realize that there are some things
they are factors
I can do say the machines
are from 1 to 10 make the bow the bow
ding of the ip the problem that if the
machines number 8 falls me down in a
sure moment how do I know
that the car has fallen and to tell the
controller looks at what the car is
fall off the balancing pool
now if the thing you want to implement
you and I have tried
and is very liable to bankruptcy
main reason is here custodian custodes
if you have heard this if it does many
networking
the problem is how do you ensure that
even the controller does not fall here you have to
make a multi-level two-tier system
controller because a controller from
it can only be your neck
bottle happened he falls all right
you can do it very robust but the
therefore controller does not work
the load balancer is google has taken off one
has practically used the
a technology he has used for many years
that is the one with which our front end
with which we give do not know if google doc com e
all our other technologies
we have an existing technology
we have applied computer and ge now
we launched it for a month and a half from
mid-October if I'm not mistaken first of
October is usable is
basically it works like this
sorry it's a level 3 dogma wars
work at regional level and therefore of
the hollow balance in europe and one in us
central a region is an array of more
zone there is always at least two types
europe west one is a region of europe
west one and yen b are two areas the part
so interesting is that you can do the
load balancing only between machines that
they are in neighboring areas but can
be different areas
this is the merit that is an area
it falls because we put it in
maintenance for a week you can
have cars in the other area and you have
have the guarantee that the load balancer
draws on a pool of machines of which
at least half of them are always right away
what you want then
the purpose of load balancing is yours
customer does not have to notice that you
go down for 5 minutes
this is the idea the beautiful part of the
balance is that to a thing called sexual
they are finished and a little more complicated there
I talk later to something called with
target on where you say
all the machines you call all the
cars
web a web 2 up to the web 10 belong
to this pool associated with this rule
an ip address is really simple ve
assure you
henceforth lippi 1 point 2.3.4 e
the public address you give to
your client or your DNS server
configured www.la mia punto com page
at this point whenever one types
that one page the dns responds to
with an ip once you have those p
the request goes to google decides
on the load balancer rule of this
forwarding room decides which machine
send the algorithm more if instead one
round robin then the first but on the a1
the second goes on the 2nd tenth
on the a10 the eleventh returns from 1
this is the main rule is the
more basic rule
then we have a concept called sa
finished scene I give you an example
suppose you want yours
customer number one go to the car
number one but every subsequent request
stay on the same machine you want that
there is a concept of session that
stay glued on the same machine
how do you guarantee a thing of the
kind then google sail by as it is
possibility you can rub I want
the murderess finished at the level of ip and di
door and in doing so the system remembers
as if it were a born table remember
the address is more source and recalls the
pool machine to which it was
associated and will continue to apply
league because you may want to do one
something like that
imagine the stupidest example e
authentication one logs in on
machine number one but I am also number
2 did not do it however this is a
bad example because nobody
would ever design a system where a
depending on the car you are going to of
make a new login and every time it would be
it would be really beautiful design
an example could be a car
which caches information e
if he doesn't have them
the discharge maybe puts us some
second, if you already have them at the level of
sail milliseconds immediately serves well
this case then you have machines
which are all the same, they are all born
the same and this is an example in my opinion
more fitting then this machine
which has in
it is convenient that the customer the user
hicks go on the same car because
probably the cache will have in cash and
of the information that this customer has
already asked for purely reasons
statistics and statistics monetize
very well in the sense if you make houses
well done you can save a
order of magnitude and sometimes 2 and not
I'm kidding it's really 120
saved for policies and techniques
caching done well so this is one
which can work a thing I have
neglected to tell you is that the load
balancer keeps these words pinging you
machines and if so
and if for 15 seconds a car is not
responses are automatically removed from
pool is marked as bad comes
marked as anna hofer and then
fifteen should be fifteen
seconds when a car does not go and
you will have this problem of course but it is
but always a trade off no after 15
seconds this machine is taken out of the pool
and therefore you have the guarantee that with good
approximation your customer will come
always hitting a car from there
the best part is the checks you can
do something amazing like this
being able to say verification I don't put anything
By the way you can say check out the
page at port 80 with slash address
check
by doing so you can hope that you
be the systems analyst and you have
php java developers wanted and these
people have written one
an application that you don't know how
functions but nothing looks at me
premise does in ciak of the system that is
fast costs little because it is anyway
we do every 15 seconds and me if i
I do the unauthenticated slash curl
look for port 80 of your car
you have to come back to me 200 if everything goes
good or 404 500 if things do not go
doing so you can give this dough
to the load balancer that automatically
will do this cech for you and will remove the
machines that do not respond to this
check independently of the class e
so however the semantics of the
your application and enter this
Of course I don't know what is in default
a diet of port 80 and you can
really try it with machines
virtual you can say apt get install a
paci on ten machines you can make a
service stop on a couple of machines
you will see that these are removed
from the Alban surgery 30 seconds which is one
quite a valuable thing now this is
a rough diagram of how long
still fantastic then this
the rough diagram to make you understand
the question I have the most and that they make me
more often on accomplished in gene and how it is
inserts with more ten gene in
a cloud architecture
ok i promised you i would talk
we're doing a bit of cloud
at the beginning we also talk about it now
this is an architecture made by ok
so a team in us did
this this beautiful this
beautiful diagram that makes you understand
that your customer here in the mobile with
a web browser with anything
usually the first the first point of
access to any one
mobile application is always a page
web that the customer sees it or not another
what when you play a game online with
I don't know which one of our clients is satin or
in any online game you play
on the iphone or on facebook anything
usually goes to access pages
web with ip ai that are served
from a web front so to speak
a peace or an engine x or anything
it is
then in the google scenario
certainly the first front and is a penn
jing app engine is very great
property and I think and I can
boast say is the only one in the world to do
this that at least you could use
wrong this is the capacity of
scale automatically in a way
horizontal means that if you just want it
set it up and he will automatically be
able to accept connections over more
cars
if a car is not enough it will create it
others and cars but scalability is
elastic so that
regardless of how many people from
how many get are going to affect
on the father on door 80 of this
car he will create more cars for
support traffic or when the
graphic I don't know we are there at night
less people to save back to
less cars and therefore is a one
accordion of cars that go up and
down in time and you only pay for
what you use which is really the
cloud based concept pay what you use
so if this is the front end that
what is computer g but surely it is a
good on is a good example of back end
rather in plain words we can say
you need a backhand sequel use
the cloud sequel
you need in backhand of items
then static objects photo images
film geographical data I don't know gis stuff of
genre use the cloud storage you have a
system does not sequel the data store
we are quite famous for the data stop
because they like it very much
that is a system basically of you
you can can put some objects that
they are gods and you have your name and surname
address phone number then vi
wake up the
also forgotten age and from this
moment, your data store
will count objects that also have the field
age but it's not like you have to change
the database is a lot and already the how
methodology allows you to adapt the
system over time and add fields in the
time then you may have to have some
algorithms to correct the data
maybe more obsolete than missing one
campus at the level of program logic
you have to assign
but more or less so we said to myself
if this is for you we are right if
this is not for you
you probably have a pocket enough
complex that deserves the creation of a
virtual machine a beautiful way to
app engine to communicate with computers
jing are the letras skew age closed and
we have launched a few months is everything
in fieri in the cloud platform and the thing
very nice is that the task you is a queue
think of a mailbox basically
a fifo queue in which appengine deposits
of the rates that must be
processed and maybe computer stays in
I listen to this queue and process these
images you have think quite a success
with sex with something we yours
customer when erika a page a
two second you have a second of time
to answer if something requires a
now it's up to you to return right away
page of history
attention we are processing yours
request we will send you the answer via
email or come back to us tomorrow with the
answer to the page of such
and why you are processing in the back end
something that will take an hour a day
what is ok so this is a good one
diagram to understand how we can
design our system
we have customers who write code
on top of our dishes for example
rightscale as I told you sell cars
virtual on top of our offer
puppet and chef then papeete ops cod
create a ruby-based system in which
you can instantiate alloy machines from
command you can use a back and also
you want you can use google like a
another competitor quietly enough
that you put the data in a key and then
then in a completely transparent manner
there is a system of verbs and entities
then create instance or delete instance or
create yourself that is transparent with respect to
back end you want to use a thing
very interesting is that you have the
possibility to access a starter pack
I think you were also told
this morning if you enter this code all
in
you have 2,000 dollars or 2,000 euros I don't have
never understood about a dollar euro dollar
you have 2 thousand dollars d
to start using app engine e
incompetent I remember app engine is
completely free if you use a
instance you have type 24 hours distances to the
day so math enough
simple to create four instances for six
hours then pull it down if I'm not mistaken though
the idea is that if you use an instance only
a single virtual machine is free
from the second onwards they started paying
ok computer gili but unfortunately you have to
pay every single machine that
used and in fact I told you
tend to be used for
back end operations operations that a
front end like benji is not able to
support yourself so you need a little
smash your head and figure out what it is
best thing to do for you one
very interesting thing who did who
of you knows a pa you don't know what
they do
then raise your hand who knows what he wants
say but produced at least to an idea of ​​what
what they are in my time is not taught
the school then I tried to
beat the pet world record a
sort if i'm not mistaken night was it
sorry we are not yet the partner theme
and the arrangement of 10 to 12
whole thing which is a typical problem of
mapreduce but for news it means the map il
problem in sub problems applies
problem in a computing unit that
can be neither virtual machines or ai
in processors will depend on the context and
then re-assemble the answer in a
controller and so indeed they did
the current world record was made by
thousand servers 11,000 corn of which 1,400
server and was one minute and 0 2 with gm
para you can do it with 1300 servers
think of a thousand units of computation e
three controllers 4 thousand mile three disks
bodies of a core each
broke the 6 second non record
I believe the interesting part is a
beat the 6-second record
at least this is my opinion
staff
the most interesting part which is the
world record was obtained
arming and configuring 1460 servers
physical
this means that it takes time
it takes at least a few months ok all
you need to configure the servers to find
of the hardware that does for you that you
which then maybe because of its advantages
you always have the hardware dedicated to all
the things
perfect for your application though
it takes time and above all what you have
made this world record what you do
go for this hardware not
recycled in some other way
obviously you can do it however not always
what you want
now nepal via google computer gene is
succeeded with the education of useful gissi
that the boys of this morning have
touched with hand
do a nice cycle for start a thousand
machines from less scardini stylization
beige with writing configures this do
to leave this and so on
a few minutes they pulled up a thousand
instances and have paid something like 500
dollars something you can do with
your starter pack starter then the
part in my opinion is interesting is that
in the cloud if you get an idea on a Saturday
afternoon and you want to try and see if
it works to write the application e
if it doesn't work you had fun
you have lost an afternoon if it works e
see some business
the only promise I can make is that
the cloud is the only thing that allows you
to indefinitely increase the
number of customer instances the size
of your system
within minutes instead of months
that is the speed of the system in the
grow if things go well or
decrease when things go wrong
where to turn off stop paying
when things are not going well unfortunately
the downside the cloud vi
lets do this very well ok
let's see if I'm done with a lot
interesting is that recently
we can do the billing per minute
we started from then we can arrived
ten minutes now my name is minute
it means that yes you give on the machine for
5 minutes paid and a twelfth
as far as I know there are other solutions
in which even for 5 minutes paid
inter has now so this is a
small advantage that you hear if
pull on many machines